nikolaus bietet sich eine dieser
magischen ansichten roms die ewige stadt
regelt sich in der mediterranen sonne
als gäbe es keine corona pandemie und
keine politische krise wegen der
gesunkenen infektionszahlen sind in rom
die korona beschränkungen gelockert
worden und die römer atmen durch für
einen moment
wir konnten es kaum erwarten sind sofort
hierher gestürzt endlich wieder ein
bisschen freiheit
jetzt können wir endlich wieder in die
bar untergehen ein panino essen das büro
verlassen und das tut gut
sosehr dürfen wir es aber auch nicht
genießen sonst werden wir wieder orangen
der zone gelb orange und rot das
ampelsystem hat in italien offenbar
wirkung entfaltet strenge auflagen wo
nötig lockerungen wenn möglich hier oben
auf dem genie colo zeigt sich die
kreativität römischer regelungen auf
andere art ebenfalls erfolgreich die vor
jahrhunderten eingeführte päpstliche
signal kann ohne sollte das
glockenläuten in ganz rom
vereinheitlichen
ein ritual zum takt dieser stadt aber
wie wirkungsvoll das heute noch ist
werden wir zur mittagsstunde erleben
doch vorher macht sich reiseführerin
annett auf den weg während sich die
deutsche römerin zusammen mit ihrem
kollegen bietet sie seit jahren
stadtführungen an in dieser schwierigen
situation online per facebook live für
die reise hungrigen in deutschland die
41 jährige lebt seit 15 jahren in der
ewigen stadt verliebt in einen römer und
geblieben mittlerweile mit zwei kindern
vor fünf jahren hat sie die
selbstständigkeit gewagt der weg bis
dahin war steinig und seit corona ist er
noch steiniger haben natürlich auch
keine turnier haben damit auch keine
einnahmen
aber wir versuchen einfach an die
zukunft zu denken wir wollen einfach
optimistisch bleiben wir wollen den
leuten den leuten in deutschland die
kann es ja auch kaum erwarten reisen zu
können
bei ihrer tour darf der john nicolo mit
der kanone nicht fehlen mittags punkt 12
in rom
papst pius der neunte hatte das signal
verfügt da ihm die kirchenglocken der
stadt zu wild durcheinander läuteten
doch so wie die glocken von rom am
mittag längst nicht mehr gleichzeitig
läuten ist auch das politische rom in
unruhe geraten zieht sich die politische
krise seit wochen hin
matteo renzi von der splitterpartei
italia wie war hatte die mitte links
koalition platzen lassen und der bis
dahin premier dieselbe konnte fand trotz
seines erfolgreichen corona
krisenmanagements keine stabile
regierungsmehrheit mehr mitten in der
pandemie erlaubt sich das politische rom
eine beschäftigung mit sich selbst bei
der ganz sicher eines wächst die
politikverdrossenheit
es wurden persönliche und
parteipolitische entscheidung getroffen
die uns in diesen zustand der
instabilität geführt haben
die regierungskrise kommt zum falschen
zeitpunkt aber wenn es hilft die
probleme zu lösen
dann soll es so sein das café jam bini
ist der treffpunkt für politikerinnen
und journalistinnen in der innenstadt
seitdem rom wie der gelbe zone ist darf
es endlich wieder öffnen
an der bar von raffaele gab es früher
ein heißes gerücht dass schnell zur
gewissheit wurde
super-mario soll es nun richten der
staatspräsident hat den ehemaligen
ezb-chef mario draghi mit der bildung
einer neuen regierung beauftragt anders
als seinem vorgänger wird ihm zugetraut
die eu milliarden aus dem corona
hilfspaket für italien zielgerichtet
einzusetzen
whatever it takes mario draghi ist der
richtige mann zur richtigen zeit
ich bin persönlich für einen neuen
regierungschef der weiß welche maßnahmen
zu ergreifen sind und der internationale
glaubwürdigkeit genießt
eines ist in diesen tagen deutlich
geworden geld allein und sei es noch so
viel kann den italienischen patienten
nicht heilen
die römischen geschäftsinhaber spüren
trotz öffnung die wirtschaftliche not
marco salvati hat zwar während der
regierungskrise ein paar edle krawatten
mehr verkauft aber insgesamt geht es ihm
schlecht ich überlebe in dem ich mich
verschuldet die geschäftsräume gehören
mir nicht ich muss weiterhin miete
zahlen
das geschäft ist nicht nur ein bisschen
eingebrochen es ist fast auf null
viele stehen vor den ruinen ihrer
wirtschaftlichen existenz die deutsche
römerin annett führt ihre virtuelle
stadtführung zu den ruinen des römischen
reichs
annett ist im sächsischen glauchau
geboren bei chemnitz als das noch
karl-marx-stadt hieß ihre familie hat
den zusammenbruch der ddr erlebt und
weiß mit krisen umzugehen als italien
vor einem jahr von corona schwer
getroffen wurde nahm der freistaat
sachsen cupid patienten auf das ihrer
heimat jetzt selbst so stark betroffen
ist betrübt sie deshalb für sie online
positive signale an ihre deutsche
community senden
damit will optimistisch bleiben versucht
ihre eigenen sorgen wegzulächeln auf das
eine oder andere verzichten
ganz logisch lange wird es nicht mehr
gehen also ich hab jetzt beiden
italienischen staaten kredit beantragt
damit ich einfach noch ein bisschen
weiter komme wer mal sehen es was ich
denke nur noch von tag zu tag ohne
touristen ist rom auf sich
zurückgeworfen die römer entdecken ihre
stadt selbst
seit einer woche haben museen und
archäologische stätten wieder geöffnet
keine langen warteschlangen vor den
vatikanischen museen kunstwerke
historische säle und gärten fast
exklusiv ohne gedränge und mit viel muße
die befürchtung ist groß dass dieses
glück nur von kurzer dauer ist denn in
mehreren regionen sind bereits die neuen
corona mutationen nachgewiesen worden
wie lange also wird diese atempause für
die römer sein einmal nur nicht an das
morgen denken selbstvergessenen der
abendsonne im moment dieses glückes
schwingt auch immer das große drama mit
in der ewigen stadt so war es immer in
rom
und so wird es wohl auch immer sein
[Musik]